this result if it is true
is that women in science may do better
with
uh male mentors um
which is that and this you know it's
related to what you were just talking
about but it's not exactly the same
which is that in other primate species
and indeed in
pre-industrial human societies
male and female social interactions
were of course mixed but they were very
distinct and in all other primate
species this is 100
true male hierarchies male dominance
hierarchies and and
female dominance hierarchies there's all
this stuff in the
in the common common discourse about
alpha males and beta males and all of
this
and very little discussion about
actually there's there's a parallel but
very much not the same
dominance hierarchy among females in
baboons in squirrel monkeys and you know
in
all of these species and in other
species you also have
the rules around what are called
phylopatry and dispersal again i'm not
telling you anything you don't know
phylopathy dispersal where you know
sex-based rules where which sex at the
point that it becomes a reproductive age
disperses and goes find another group in
which sex stays in its natal clan
um and whichever sex stays whichever sex
is so called phyllopatric
tends to have um the more kin-based
rule-rich model of dominance hierarchy
be it female or male than the one who um
on the sex who's going to be dispersing
in in that case
so anyway all of this is true we know
that is true
and what we're trying to do in the late
20th and early 21st century
is reconfigure some traditional rules
around separate female and male lines of
of hierarchy in the workplace for
instance and it's not easy
it's not simple and frankly
one of the things that makes it not easy
and not simple
is that men find it pretty easy and
without thinking about it
you know just natural which is a word
that isn't great to use here but to
compete with one another
and so do women and competition between
men looks like the way we all think of
competition between men typically
looking and competition between women
doesn't look like fisticuffs it looks
more covert it looks more about
changing of social reputation etc but
it may well be and you know anecdotally
i think i have i have seen this not just
for myself but
across many of my peers that is easier
effectively to walk into a situation
across sex
and not be seen as a competitor right
away and thus get a more collaborative
dynamic
going more easily so it's effectively a
way to include
to get around the older dominance
hierarchies that are within sex and you
know when will dominance
hierarchies emerge that are you know
that are together with both sexes of
course they will
but they're newer and we have a better
chance of more easily changing the rules
all right so uh i agree with that
although a i want to know whether it's
symmetrical
right a male walking into a uh
a system of females may be disruptive
of the collaborative instinct who knows
well but i don't say a system of
male like a woman walking into a system
of males and this isn't so
this study which i again i didn't read
all of it but i read a little bit of it
you know they're not looking at like phd
advisors in the graduate students they
specifically aren't they're looking at
publication records where there's a
senior author and a junior author
and looking at the the sex between them
uh and so that's not
you know sometimes these papers have
eight ten forty people on them but
um and i have no idea how carefully they
looked um but in general
um they were looking at dyadic
relationships they thought they were
looking at diatic relationships which is
to say one
you know one older person a one one
senior person one junior person
and their rubric for that which is
something like you know did you get your
phd more than seven years ago or less
than seven years ago so
yeah it's a little bit it's course it's
course um
but it's not as you know it's not a man
walking into a system you know
a group of people responding i was
responding to what you were saying about
a dynamic i wasn't talking about the
paper in that case right so
you know about the ability to generate
collaboration was what i was responding
to
um the so i i do want to say though
there's a possibility
of something more you know the reason
that the philosophy of science part
matters is that if the hypothesis
pre-exists
the test right then you know that it is
not confirmation
bias right so you know that what isn't
confirmation
if the hypothesis comes if the
hypothesis
follows from the test in other words
what you really have is an empirical
observation and then a hypothesis and
then these things are very frequently
reported as if the hypothesis preceded
the test
then the point is you you haven't really
tested it you have not tested and so you
don't have the
the the power that comes from the
scientific
method in this case though if the test
is accurate and it reflects the
hypothesis that existed beforehand
even better that they didn't know about
it in some sense because they couldn't
have been responding to it or unlikely
to be
then the question is what does that say
about it reflects well on the model that
generated the hypothesis and the
prediction yep
so what does that model say one of the
things that model says
is that there is a male mode that
is actually i don't want to say integral
but is strongly consistent with
scientific progress and that male model
i'm going to argue has to do with
what we have described as taking the
piss out of each other that there is a
way that men who view each other
as collaborators will still
you know seek each other's weaknesses
poke at them prod them
you know there is a sort of competitive
mode
that results in you becoming
anti-fragile because
your intimate partners are finding
what's wrong with your work
yeah so that you can take care of it
before you unveil it to the world that
kind of thing
yeah and that women have a system
i'm not saying that any of this has to
be but women have a system in which
with those they are collaborating with
there tends to be a reflexive support
a building up right a build building
people up
and so the point is that this might have
an
implication now here's the thing you had
male mentors mostly male mentors in
graduate school
yes okay um so arnold cloogy
dick alexander um i had mostly male
mentors also but
uh elizabeth calco stands out to me the
marvelous
she is now dead unfortunately but anyway
the
most extraordinary bat woman of all
who herself had been mentored by charles
handley
so anyway here's the thing if this paper
is accurate
and it correctly reveals that the
hypothesis
that was on the table which is that
there are male and female kinds of
wisdom that have been transmitted and
that they have to be transmitted across
in order to bring everyone in on the
endeavor
then this predicts some further things
right
oh i i should point out the second
result here is kind of interesting too
which was that mentoring females
appeared to have a cost to the mentors
going forward also
so that actually yes so that actually is
suggestive
of a mechanism here which is to say that
the dynamic between mentor and mentee
um might be less effective
in other words if you imagine just as a
placeholder so
are you sure about that result did you
you didn't get that from the abstract
did you
no i think i did so you have a reduction
in the gain of female mentors
right for the mentees yeah that's not
that that to me does not read
as a cost to me well we will have to go
back and find i think that's what it
does mean but
um but anyway um
where were we sorry to distract no
that's okay
uh in any case one way or the other what
this predicts going forward if the model
is accurate
and this is a proper test of it which is
robust
then it predicts actually that the
effect will decay
over time that is to say that females
who have been mentored by males and
gotten the benefited
benefit of it will be better mentors to
females that they mentor in the future
right so second order male mentorship
yeah i mean i hate to put it that way
because i don't think it's like that men
deserve
credit for it but what i do think is
that the answer
look you and i well and and you know if
if my obs
if my hypothesis is correct which i
expect it to be
i'm not sure but i expect it also to be
weaker than
what you're talking about but if it is
true then it would also go in the
opposite direction
and so you would have a benefit to a
potential benefit
uh to men being mentored by women but
you could have second order female
mentorship in which a man who had been
mentored by a woman
might be um might be you know less
competitive say
with his male mentees than he would be
if he had been mentored by a man himself
yeah and certainly this being a complex
system you would expect many such
effects to be
over layered with each other and
figuring out which ones you know
had what strength of effect would be you
know a whole line of inquiry that might
might arise here yeah um so i'm reminded
but you're going no go ahead um i'm
reminded of the conversation i had
uh with with tom on impact theory this
week which i don't think is out yet but
um i was on his podcast this week and we
were talking a little bit about
about sex and gender and roles in the
workplace and he said
um he's a very successful entrepreneur
he said
i tom when i'm leading teams that are
entirely male
it's much easier for me but when i'm
leading teams that are mixed sex
they're more productive and this is
something i kept coming back to
throughout our conversation i thought
that you know that
that is a beautiful observation and i
kind of hope it holds
right it doesn't surprise me that it's
easier if it's all if it's all one sexy
and you know he basically
he used some of this kind of language
that you know he i don't think he said
we take the piss out of each other he's
like i can i can tell
you know my my teammates even when i'm
the leader that they're being fuck-ups
and they need to up their game
and it's expected and if i don't do that
then they have no way to know
and the the work on mixed sex teams is
slower
and i have to be thinking about these
people's feelings in a way i don't have
to be thinking about these people's
feelings and it's it's a lot more
chaotic but
but he asserts and this is not you know
he's not being politically correct
he asserts that they are ultimately more
productive now
so i've got two things i want to get to
and i don't want to forget either of
them
one of them is that that is suggestive
of
an analog of hybrid vigor and this is
another point that i think we've been
hinting around and we've made a couple
times but i really want it to be
explicit
so hybrid vigor is the uh
recognition and this is this comes from
breeding this is actually a genetic
phenomenon
in uh artificial selection of things
like farm animals
if you take two purebred critters and
you breed them together they often have
extraordinary capacity relative to their
parents right and there can be a number
of reasons for this one
purebreds may be hobbled by being
purebreds in other words the inbreeding
that comes along with
getting a pure line can be destructive
and so this can be liberating of that
but it also can be that there are
advantages
to borrowing from two millions so to the
extent that there is male and female
wisdom and you have a team
in which people are native to both of
these languages
that team potentially if you can figure
out how to get it not to trip over
itself
has both modes available yes yes
and so okay so the last point i want to
make here
is an awful lot of what is going on
in academia is based on the assertion
that the characteristics of the person
at the front of the room
dictate whether or not the students and
the chairs are going to be effectively
able to learn from them
unless you see somebody who looks like
you at the front of the room you've got
a problem
right now my point would be that is
nonsense that is not to say there's no
component of truth in it
i think that there is a going to be some
positive effect of having somebody you
very easily identify with
at the front of the room and some
component of that will be based on
superficial characteristics
but the idea that you should upend
a faculty in order to get people at the
front of the room who look like the
students which is by the way crazy
because the students don't tend to look
like each other so
how do you even do it without
segregating right chimerism
right but um but the idea that we should
be
refactoring the world so that you know
the most important thing is that the
people at the front of the
room have the same skin color or sexual
orientation or whatever it is
they're sacrificing academic rigor for a
failure of imagination on the part of
students
right and you're also potentially
sacrificing even to the extent that the
world looks the way it does because of
unfairness
to the extent that some people have
the insight into how the work gets done
if you want to make the world fair
whatever they know has to be
democratized
right and in some sense that's going to
make for very uncomfortable conclusions
like
you know you might want to you know have
a male mentor if you're female because
it it's going to make you a stronger
competitor going forward in a world
where
some large fraction of the people you're
dealing with are male i i don't know
that that's where it comes from but
that's at least a
a viable possibility so
anyway oh but the final conclusion here
is that the demand
by those who are outraged by this is
that the paper be
retracted right and yes there are some
valid concerns that are raised about the
methodology of the paper as there
always are it is not hard to take
almost any paper of any complexity and
find things that
weren't done well that opened the
possibility of some other explanation
it's very hard to do perfect work right
it almost never happens
but it appears that there is this
motivation to find anything and
everything wrong with this paper
in order to justify the claim that it is
so bad that not only does it need to be
challenged
but it needs to be retracted because the
damage that comes from it
and this is so much the ethos of the
moment where you know a paper that is
wrong
has to be held accountable for its error
whether or not that was the intent
because after all harm is the you know
the end-all and be-all and people are
certainly going to be harmed
by the idea that you know that one
might wonder about whether or not you
know wisdom is
being properly transmitted based on the
sex of the
mentor right so anyway i i just think
this is
emblematic of everything we're seeing
yeah no i think you're right it's
it's conclusion driven and this the
methodology is flawed therefore you must
retract
line of activists is becoming is
becoming the go-to line right it's
exactly the one they used against lisa
lipman's work
on rapid onset gender dysphoria which is
i believe
the uh term that she actually um
introduced in the paper in question and
um i believe in that case i don't
remember the specifics that it was
pulled and she did revise and
went back out and almost nothing changed
and so you know the the journal was able
to basically say that they had caved to
the activists
and the work is still out there because
it was it was good work and it's
important work
but anyway the the point there being
and like here there's literally no
information at all
in a claim there are methodological
flaws in a paper that's yes
you know too bad and that's part of what
the peer review process is supposed to
be about and to find
and papers that are deeply flawed should
not be published
etc etc etc but in this era
the claim that there are methodological
problems is
simply another activist tactic and
should be treated as such
yeah which is which is a shame because
legitimate methodological flaws that
were not caught in peer review
do warrant a very careful um critique
um and you know and thought about
whether or not a paper should have been
published
but that's not what's going on no it's
not and
i would just say even if your bent is
that this is all about
structural unfairness in the system one
interpretation of the paper is that it
has unearthed
a serious kind of structural unfairness
right
to the extent that this result is robust
right it now invites a conversation
about what might be causing it and it
may be
kinds of wisdom that needs to be
transmitted in various ways it may be
just
purely the bias of people downstream who
don't take you seriously if you had a
female mentor who knows
but the point is if it's a result well
that's if the result is robust
then you know it tells us there's a
phenomenon that we need to be finding
yeah there's a phenomenon that we need
to be finding the conversation needs to
be allowed to be had
uh if you stop the conversation by
retracting a paper these conversations
will continue to be had they'll just be
underground out of you by the activists
and
and and get stronger frankly i hope
um but you know those two let's see you
just said two possible mechanisms of
explanation
um one of which is what we've been
talking about and one of which is well
maybe it's about you know the bias of
people downstream who don't take you as
seriously if you had a female mentor
i think that doesn't apply here because
we're not actually talking about the
standard
definition of mentor we're talking about
people who've published um with people
as opposed to
being their phd advisors but take that
standard model well
you can you can what i was saying was
didn't
doesn't it's not sensitive to which kind
of mentor in other words if people
in your little field are aware of who
you've published with
that could potentially be a factor sure
okay i guess i guess so
um i think if i'm
it's really hard to steal man this
position here um but
if if i'm gonna try to steal man their
position
i would say it's absolutely critical
that
um you know even if we are reasonable
human beings that we can grant
that there are different kinds of wisdom
that have tended to travel on the male
and female lines and we would like
cross-pollination between them and
therefore
there might be benefit to having men and
women working together hey
look at that it is still it is
deplorable and abhorrent and we must
stop immediately in its tracks the bias
that is simply um you know opposed to
someone on the basis of some immutable
demographic characteristic
stopping this conversation because some
people will use it to justify that
bias i think is what is going on in
their heads and see i did a terrible job
of still emanating that because i
can't do it but i but i do think that
even though probably almost none of the
activists know that that's what they're
scared of
it's that it's this result will be used
to justify
a bias and what they've imagined is the
only explanation for
this being beneficial is bias and it's a
little bit like
you know the four to one ratio of male
to female software engineers at google
it must be biased that's the only
possible explanation no
no there are many other possible
explanations and
i believe strongly that most of them
have far more explanatory power than
bias
is there still bias presumably yes
should we be trying to eradicate it
obviously should we not talk about it in
order to not give anyone any sense that
there's bias
or like what what was that how did you
even get there right so
i so the activist response is actually
counterproductive even to
their honorable goals and as to their
dishonorable goals i don't know why
we're playing games with them at all
yeah um so the whole thing
a i would say you know there are lots of
cruddy there are lots of people who
aren't very good
up in the upper echelons of science and
certainly in
the vast ranks of those doing science
that said
the work is subtle and
there is a great deal that is learned as
somebody who figures out how to wield
these tools properly
comes to that knowledge and the
activists are involved
in a response to it
as if there was nothing there and their
basic point is look we can spot the
truth
we know what the truth is and so if you
come up with a paper that's offensive
relative to this model that is the truth
then of course you should retract it why
would we want anything but the truth in
these scientific journals
the answer is you don't know what you're
freaking talking about you have no idea
how
complex things like sociality are and
therefore
you know how messy the truth is going to
be and the real question that they
you know don't seem willing to ask
is you know if we have the truth which
we don't
yet right we won't ever fully get there
it's a diminishing returns problem but
if we had the truth
how bad is it now my sense having spent
all of my adult life in this game
is the truth is messy but it's actually
way better than it could be
right in fact these problems are
solvable but we're never going to get
there
if we're you know fighting over whether
or not we are allowed to
consider the mass
you